[Music]
you've carried out lots of mass
participation studies what is a mass
participation study and maybe you could
answer that by giving giving some
examples or any example that comes to
mind
as best participation studies as the
name suggests is studies involving lots
of people
and
it was a life-changing experience for me
uh surrounding my very first one
so i got to university heart for cheer
after studying in edinburgh and i think
within a couple of weeks sitting at my
desk this email came around because
email had been invented by them
from the uh the bbc and they said we're
we're going to be doing a mass
participation experiment as part of
science week in the uk
and
we haven't got any ideas for what we
should do so we're emailing all
scientists and psychologists anyone got
any ideas
and it would have been the easiest email
to just deleted and thought well you
know there's thousands of people getting
that but at the time i was working on
the psychology of lying
and i thought well wouldn't it be fun
to suggest that uh politicians from the
three main political parties which we
had in the uk at the time went on
television and they lied and told the
truth and then the public voted on which
they thought was the lie and we could
work out
which party had got the best liars
i sent it in i sent it in it must have
taken me i don't know 30 seconds to
write that email
and it changed my life
because about two weeks later
simon singh who's a
a very big author and uh mathematician i
was working the bbc at the time phoned
me up he said i'm working on tomorrow's
world which is the tv program that this
is going to go out on and we've chosen
yours as the winning star this is going
to be a mass participation study we're
going to get the whole country trying to
detect lies
and so we contacted the political
parties said will you come on and lie
and tell the truth and they all said no
that's ridiculous
that's right so we thought this is the
end of the study and then we eventually
decided uh to
convince a very well-known political
interviewer over here at the times robin
day
i think was kind of walter cronkite
figure would be the sort of equivalent
in the states
to come and lie and tell the truth
so he goes on to national television i
interview him twice once he's lying once
he's telling the truth and we open the
phone lines
and we had no idea whether like 10
people were going to phone in or 15 we
got about 30 000 people
it was incredible in about 10 minutes
this is all in a live tv program
and so i had to look at those results as
they come in turn them around very
quickly and then interpret the results
on tv
and the
uh the fact of the matter was that when
we watch people lie and tell the truth
on video or film or tv we're really not
very good at detecting a lie and that
the results supported that about 50 50
there's chance split
uh however we'd also run two other parts
of the study we'd broadcast just the
audio on national radio
and we put the transcripts into a
national newspaper
and when you focus people's attention on
the verbal cues
which is where the really good stuff is
in terms of signals for lying they
become much better light detectors
so that 50 percent went up to about 61
up to about 70 accuracy
just when you read the transcripts or
you listen to it on the radio because
suddenly all the ums and the r's and the
lack of detail the lack of eyes me my
and so on they all jump out at you where
when you're overwhelmed with visual
information you just don't spot that and
that was my first ever mass
participation experiment and because of
that they came back to me year after
year and i invented loads of them for
them
all right i want to hear more examples
but
could you explain or elaborate on the
lack of i me mine as an indicator
with lie detection i've done quite a bit
of it over the years
what you're looking for are movements
away from what's called the baseline
we've all got a sort of signature in
terms of how much eye contact we we make
when we're talking or whether we
say the words i me mine or adjectives or
whatever
and once you've established that
baseline what you see is that liars have
a fairly consistent pattern of movement
against that baseline
so one is a lack of detail
shorter sentences
bigger response time which is the time
between the end of a question and the
beginning of an answer and also a
psychological distancing they don't like
saying me my i all those sorts of things
which wrap them up in the story
and and so it's it's a good little hint
and tip as somebody you know it's
evidence that somebody might be lying to
you
you